"
A DAY OF RECKONING FOR ALEC
BALDWIN.
THEY WILL FACE 2 COUNT OF
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER IN THE
DEATH OF HUTCHINS.
IT COULD PUT ALEC BALDWIN BEHIND
BARS FOR 5 YEARS.
AND THIS INTERVIEW ALEC BALDWIN
DID IS COMING BACK TO HAUNT HIM.
>> I DIDN'T PULL THE TRIGGER.
>> YOU NEVER PULLED THE TRIGGER?
>> NO, I WOULD NEVER POINT A GUN
AT ANYONE AND PULL THE TRIGGER.
NEVER.
>> THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOLD
JUDGE JEANINE THAT ALEC BALDWIN
IS NOT BEING TRUTHFUL AND
HUTCHINS WOULD BE ALIVE IF HE
HAD DONE HIS JOB.
>> WE BELIEVE HE PULLED THE
TRIGGER.
THE FBI LAB REPORT CONFIRMS
THAT.
THE TRIGGER WAS PULLED.
>> HIS STATEMENT IS NOT CORRECT
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> WE DON'T BELIEVE IT IS.
>> MR. BALDWIN HAD A DUTY TO
NEVER HOLD A GUN AND POINT IT AT
A PERSON WHILE PULLING THE
TRIGGER.
HE ALSO HAD A DUTY AS AN ACTOR
AND PRODUCER TO HAVE THE BULLETS
CHECKED.
WE BELIEVE BALDWIN AS A PRODUCER
KNOWS EVERYTHING THAT GOES ON,
ON THE SET.
THERE WERE A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
A COUPLE OF ACCIDENTAL
DISCHARGES.
THERE WAS A LOT OF SAFETY
CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT TO
THE ATTENTION OF MANAGEMENT.
HE DID NOTHING ABOUT IT.
THIS WAS A LOOSE AND RECKLESS
SCENE WHERE SAFETY WAS
COMPROMISED.
JUST TO SAVE MONEY.
>> THE DECISION TO CHARGE
BALDWIN IS NOT EASY GIVEN THE
MEDIA CIRCUS AROUND THE CASE.
>> DID YOU FEEL ANY PRESSURE TO
GO ONE WAY OR THE OTHER?
>> WE LOOKED AT THIS CASE FOR
A LONG TIME.
SURE THERE IS A LOT OF MEDIA
ATTENTION.
ALEC BALDWIN IS AN A -LIST
ACTOR.
WE WERE JUST LOOKING AT THE
FACTS OF THE CASE.
ALEC BALDWIN IS AN ACTOR.
THERE IS A LOT OF HYPE AROUND
THAT.
BUT HE IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW.
NO, WE DON'T FEEL PUBLIC
PRESSURE.
WE ARE PROSECUTORS.
WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING AND
WHAT THE FACTS SUPPORT.
IT SUPPORTS INVOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER.
>> ANOTHER INTERESTING PART OF
JUDGE JEANINE'S INTERVIEW WHEN
SHE ASKED IF BALDWIN WAS WILLING
TO WORK WITH INVESTIGATORS.
>> DID BALDWIN COOPERATE?
>> YES, HE COOPERATED IN THAT HE
DID WILLING TURN OVER HIS PHONE
AFTER NEGOTIATIONS WITH HIS
LAWYERS.
>> AND JUDGE JEANINE'S REACTION
AFTER THIS LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHETHER HE WOULD TAKE A PLEA.
>> WILL YOU ENGAGE IN PLEA
NEGOTIATIONS WITH BALDWIN?
>> I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT AT
THIS POINT.
IT WOULD BE UNETHICAL FOR
A PROSECUTOR TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> JUDGE, CONGRATULATIONS
GETTING THAT EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
WHAT WAS YOUR MAIN TAKE AWAY?
>> WELL, THAT THE PROSECUTOR IS
A VERY STRAIGHT SHOOTER, SORRY
TO USE THAT PUN.
SHE IS FOCUSSED ON THE LAW AND
THE FACTS.
SHE KNEW SHE WAS COMING UP
AGAINST A CASE THAT IS WORLDWIDE
AND IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH THE
BURDEN OF PROOF IS INCREASED
WITH THE JURY IN THIS CASE.
SHE'S NOT LETTING THAT BOTHER
HER.
IT'S CLEAR TO HER THAT IT WAS
A SET WHERE THE SAFETY WAS
COMPROMISED.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE INTO THE
ACCOUNT THE SAFETY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS.
HE HAD NOTICE OF IT.
THE ARMERROR ALSO CHARGED WITH
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER.
SHE DISCHARGED LIVE ROUNDS.
EVERYONE KNEW THIS WAS
A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
THE TRUTH IS THAT BALDWIN LIED
WHEN HE SAID I WOULD NEVER POINT
A GUN AND PULL THE TRIGGER.
THAT'S A LIE.
BASED ON THE TYPE OF GUN.
IT'S SINGLE ACTION.
YOU HAVE TO PULL THE TRIGGER.
THE FORENSIC EVIDENCE -- I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE IS ANY VIDEO OF
HIM SHOOTING HUTCHINS.
THEY HAVE A THIRD DEFENDANT WHO
AGREED TO TESTIFY AND PLED
GUILTY TO THE UNLAWFUL USE OF
A WEAPON.
HE WILL TESTIFY AGAINST BALDWIN
AND THE OTHER DEFENDANT.
SHE NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON
THE SET.
THEY DID IT FOR MONEY.
A LIFE WAS LOST.
SHE HAD REPEATED NOTICE THERE
WAS A PROBLEM.
I WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT.
I WATCHED A COUPLE OF
INTERVIEWS.
EVERYBODY SAID WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT LIVE ROUND CAME FROM.
IS IT RELEVANT?
MAYBE YES, MAYBE NO.
DEPENDS ON THE JURY.
WHAT IS RELEVANT IS HOW ALEC
BALDWIN HANDLED THE GUN ON THE
SET WHERE THEY KNEW THERE WERE
PROBLEMS WITH LIVE ROUNDS AND
WHERE HE USED THAT GUN AND
PULLED THE TRIGGER AT A HUMAN
BEING IN THE PRIME OF HER LIFE.
THE MOTHER OF A SON WHO IS DEAD
BECAUSE OF HIS ACTIONS.
>> WHEN YOU DID THE INTERVIEW
WITH STEPHANOPOULOS AND SAID I
NEVER PULLED THE TRIGGER.
AFTER SHE DIED HE NEVER SAID I
I IMAGINE HE WOULD HAVED THAT
INITIALLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
I DIDN'T TOUCH IT.
>> I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE
CASES, EVERYBODY HAS A GROUP
AROUND THEM OF FRIENDS.
OF PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY KNOW
WHAT TO SAY OR DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
SAYING USE THIS AS AN EXCUSE.
PEOPLE LISTEN TO IT.
KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT!
THE MORE YOU SAY THE BETTER FOR
ME WHEN I WAS A PROSECUTOR.
IF YOU LIE IT DIDN'T HELP YOU.
>> AROUND THE TABLE?
>> I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
FIND HOW THAT LIVE ROUND GOT
THERE.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST QUESTION.
WHAT IF IT WAS DELIBERATE?
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
AS BAD AS THIS WAS.
THERE WAS NO INTENT TO KILL THIS
WOMAN.
>> HE IS NOT CHARGED WITH
INTENT.
>> I KNOW BUT THEY NEED TO FIND
OUT HOW THE BULLET GOT IN THERE.
WHAT IF THAT WAS INTENTIONAL.
>> BUT HIS ACTION CREATING THE
DEATH.
PICKED UP A GUN.
>> THAT HE THOUGHT HAD A BLANK
IN IT.
>> ANYONE WITH A GUN.
TAKING A GUN ON A SET WHERE HE
IS CHARGED AS AN ACTOR AND
A PRODUCER.
A MAN WHO KNOWS IT'S NOT SAFE.
FOR HIM NOT TO LOOK AT THAT GUN
AND DECIDE FOR HIMSELF WHETHER
IT'S SAFE, THAT WOULD BE LIKE
YOU SAYING, HERE'S GUN.
NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
I GO OUT ON AVENUE OF THE
AMERICAS AND POINT IT AT SOMEONE
AND PULL THE TRIGGER AND SAY HE
TOLD ME IT WAS A COLD GUN.
>> THAT'S NOT AT ALL LIKE THIS.
>> YES, IT IS.
ONCE YOU HANDLE A GUN IT'S YOUR
OBLIGATION TO FOLLOW THE RULES
OF SAFETY.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE BEGUN
TRAINING.
>> WE COULD BE TRIED FOR
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER IF
SOMEONE PUT A LIVE ROUND IN THE
GUN?
>> HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
WAS GOING ON, ON THE SET.
>> I AGREE.
I THINK THERE IS A CHARGE CHANCE
HE ENDS UP IN PRISON.
BUT HE AS EIGHT KIDS.
>> SO WHAT?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I WAS GOING TO SAY MAYBE IT'S
A RELIEF TO BE IN A MINIMUM
SECURITY PRISON WHEN YOU HAVE
EIGHT KIDS.
BACK OFF!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THIS IS PROOF WE LIVE IN
A VIDEO GAME.
A HARD-CORED LEFTIST WHO
CONDEMNED REPUBLICANS AND SAYING
THE NRA HAS BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS
ENDS UP WITH BLOOD ON HIS HANDS
AFTER KILLING A YOUNG WOMAN WITH
A HANDGUN.
NOT INTENTIONALLY, BUT IT'S
CARELESS.
THAT MATTERS.
IT WAS SUCH A STUPID DECISION TO
HIRE THIS WOMAN BECAUSE OF HER
DAD OR BECAUSE SHE WAS EDGY.
HE HAD TATTOOS.
>> SHE WAS CHEAP.
>> BUT IT WAS A STUPID PATH.
NRA INSTRUCTORS ARE READY AND
ABLE TO ASSIST.
THEY DEMONIZED THE NRA SO MUCH
THEY DON'T DO THAT.
IF YOU HAD SOMEBODY THERE ON THE
SET, YOU WOULD HAVE PREVENTED
THIS FROM HAPPENING.
THEY THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT.
THIS IS SO INTERESTING.
I WONDER WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THIS WAS AN OUTSPOKEN
CONSERVATIVE AND NOT LIBERAL.
THERE WOULD BE NO KID GLOVES.
WE EXPRESS EMPATHY FOR THE
FAMILY AND THE VICTIM.
THIS IS THE WORST EXPERIENCE OF
HIS LIFE.
HE ACTUALLY KILLED A PERSON.
THEY WOULD NOT AFFORD US THE
SAME LUXURY IF IT WAS ONE OF US.
>> JESSE?
>> I DON'T THINK ALEC BALDWIN
CAN GO TO TRIAL.
CUT A PLEA.
I WOULD CUT THAT PLEA IN A HEART
BEAT.
HE IS PROBABLY DUMB ENOUGH TO
TAKE THE STAND IN HIS OWN
OFFENSE AND WOULD GET ROCKED ON
CROSSED.
IT COULD BE TELEVISED.
IT COULD WRECK HIS ENTIRE
CAREER.
HE IS LOOKING AT 5 YEARS AND HE
HAS A LOT OF KIDS AND BILLS.
HE NEEDS TO GO BACK TO ACTING.
BEFORE THE TRIAL OR AFTER
SENTENCING YOUR EARNING POWER IS
SHOT.
HE UNLOADED ALL OF THIS PRICEY
REAL ESTATE TO SETTLE THE CASE
CIVILLY.
HIS LAWYER GOT NAMED TO 40 UNDER
40 HOT LAWYER LIST.
YOUNG AND HUNGRY AND TALENTED
AND WANTS TO MAKE A NAME FOR
HIMSELF.
HE IS AN ART LIT GATOR.
HE LOOKS AT STOLEN ART PIECES.
THIS IS A CASE HE'S NEVER HAD TO
HANDLE.
I AM WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
I THINK TAKE THE PLEA IF THEY
GIVE IT TO AND YOU GET ON WITH
YOUR LIFE AND SAY YOU ARE SORRY.
I RESPECT THIS D.A.
LAST YEAR I SAID THE D.A. WOULD
NOT INDICT.
SHE HAS IT IN HER AND TREATED
BALDWIN LIKE ANY JOE.
I THINK IF IT GOES TO TRIAL SHE
WILL GET A CONVICTION.
>> MAXIMUM SENTENCE IS 6.5.
>> THAT'S A LONG TIME.
>> JESSICA?
>> I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
HAS BEEN SAID.
I WONDERED ABOUT HOW THE LIVE
ROUND GOT THERE.
IT'S AN INTERESTING POINT ABOUT
THE SET WHERE UNION WORKERS WERE
WALKING OFF SAYING IT'S TOO
UNSAFE.
TWO CREWS DID THAT.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT BALDWIN
DECLINED TO HAVE THE GUN CHECKED
BUT TOOK THE WORD OF THE
AD/SECOND IN COMMAND TO SAY IT'S
A COLD GUN.
NO PROBLEM.
THAT'S ON HIM.
I WONDER ALSO.
ACTORS ARE SO HUNGRY FOR
PRODUCER TITLES.
I WONDER IF THAT WILL CHANGE.
IF YOU WANT THIS KIND OF
LIABILITY AS WELL ON TOP OF IT.
I LISTENED TO A GUN SAFETY
EXPERT TALK ABOUT THIS.
HE SAID BECAUSE IT WAS AN
ACCIDENT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT
A CRIME.
>> YES.
>> IT'S SOMETHING WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT.
WE SEE GUNS IN MOVIES
CONSTANTLY.
I THINK PEOPLE GET SO CASUAL
ABOUT IT.
ACCIDENTS CAN HAPPEN.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS DID.
I WONDER HOW PEOPLE PLANNING
THEIR NEXT FILM FEEL ABOUT THIS.
>> JUDGE, AN INCREDIBLE
INTERVIEW.
>> ON PRIME-TIME?
>> I AM ON PRIME-TIME AND
"HANNITY."
>> KEEP WORKING.
MUCH MORE FROM JUDGE'S S